لمن الواحد يقول انه صار بيشوف اخبار
عجيبه يعني مبالغ الخبر الجاي خير
دليل ففي الهند في مسؤول رسمي امر بتصريف
خزان مياه عملاق لانه جواله طاح فيه
بالضبط زي ما سمعتم وفي فيديوهات وصور
الرجل مفتش اغذيه رسمي والاحد الماضي كان
بيتصور سلفي جنب الخزان
طاح جواله السامسونج اللي سعره يبدو انه
1200 دولار او شيء زي كده يعني فجام بدايه
جاب غواصين محليين امرهم انهم ينزلوا
يفتشوا على التليفون ولما ما لقوا جاب
مضخات وبدا يصرف مياه الخزان جنس التصريف
شغال ثلاثه ايام وتم تفريغ اكثر من
مليونين لتر مياه كل هذا على التليفون
حقهم يعني
تخيلوا المشهد يعني المياه اللي تفرغت
بتكفي
1500 فدان خلال الصيف كاملا ووفق
التقديرات والمنطقه اللي صارت فيها الواقع
ابشركم منطقه معرضه لخطر الجفاف يعني كافر
كل الاصعده يعني طيب اللي شفتوه عاد في
المقاطع قاعد تحته الشمسيه هذا هو هذا هو
جالس كذا مروق تحت الشمسيه بيطمن على سعر
عمليات البحث عن جواله مشاهد التصريف هذه
انتشرت من هنا وطبعا الناس جن جنونها من
هنا فطلع المس اولا وصرح لوسائل الاعلام
محليه انه هذه مياه غير صالحه للاستعمال
ولحتى في الراي وقال لهم انه معي اذن من
مسؤول كبير عشان اصرفها وطلع بعدها في
مقطع ثاني بنفسه بالصوت والصوره وبكل ثقه
كذا واتهم الاعلان بالمبالغه وقال انه
الاجزاء اللي تم تفريغها ان الجزء الفائض
في الخزان وكلها لترات قليله يعني وانه
ترى اخذ اذن مسؤول يعمل كده وحتى المسؤول
قال له انه هذا لا راح يفيد المزارعين
يعني كمان وقال انه كان حريص على التلفون
لانه
تظلموه يعني عمليه التفريغ وقفت لما وصل
مسؤول تاني بعد سلسله شكاوى من الناس
والمسؤول ابو تلفون هذا طبعا تم ايقافه عن
العمل وقالوا واعلنوا انه لن نعود لوظيفته
يعني مو ابشركم بعد القصه الحزينه هذه
كلها ولد رمى هذا كله التلفون الجيوب بعد
كل هذا يعني ابشركم لقيت التليفون بس ما
بيشتغل لانه خلاص خربان فيعني كل الموضوع
مكلوف فايده
[موسيقى]